Marion James Kim Jung GAO's well thank
you very much for joining us at a time
when so many parents are cooped up at
home with their kids and still trying to
work there's one guy who can really
relate find the most animals and what
will it mean for for the wider region I
think one of your children's just walked
in you might remember Robert E Kelly a
political science professor who went
viral in 2017 when his wife and kids
hilariously interrupted his televised
interview on the BBC by Polish North
Korea well Robert returned to the news
network on Thursday and this time his
family joined him but on purpose the
family lives in South Korea and as
Robert was trying to talk about the
conditions there amid the corona virus
outbreak his kids Marion and James are
doing that thing that kids do causing
chaos ask for Roberts wife she's a mood
here's what she had to say about being
stuck at home with the kids during
quarantine it's very difficult to stay
in the house long time preach people
play calm try too far away from the
people prior to the new interview Robert
tweeted this pic with his son writing
this is what happens when I sit down at
my desk now to try to work it is
basically impossible for me to work now
he had to quote be kind to your
employees with kids after two weeks
penned up in the house those kids are
gonna be climbing the walls but Robert
isn't the only person struggling to work
with kids in the house as I hear it in
the quarantine I start off by morning
Jimmy Fallon had a heck of a time trying
to get through his monologue with his
daughters Winnie and Frannie or running
amuck I'll get you a dummy move okay
alright Freddy here you sit here for
right now let me go get a gummy all
right
you